la ira se extiende por las calles de
sudán barricadas llamas y bloqueos hacen
parte del panorama de la capital tras la
toma del poder por parte de las fuerzas
armadas del país
lo que está haciendo el ejército es una
traición a los ciudadanos ahora es
importante que todos los ciudadanos
sudaneses actúen y salgan a la calle
para impedir que las fuerzas militares
lleven a cabo las operaciones el
descontento se apoderó de los sudaneses
tras el arresto del primer ministro de
la anp doc y otros altos funcionarios
por parte del ejército del país poniendo
fin al proceso de transición democrática
que vivía la nación desde la caída del
dictador omar al bashir en 2019
hemos decidido decretar el estado de
emergencia en todo el país segundo
disolver el gobierno y el consejo
soberano el golpe militar suscitó una
ola de rechazo como el del presidente de
la unión africana el presidente hace un
llamado para que se reanuden las
conversaciones entre los civiles y los
militares en el marco de la declaración
política y el decreto constitucional el
presidente reafirma que el diálogo y el
consenso son el único camino para salvar
el país y su transición democrática está
unidos anunció la suspensión de una
importante ayuda financiera de 700
millones de dólares para la transición
sudanesa y manifestó su apoyo hacia la
ciudadanía
estamos del lado del pueblo sudanés el
pueblo sudanés ha expresado claramente
sus aspiraciones de que continúe la
transición a la democracia
y continuaremos apoyando esta transición
incluso si es necesario exigiendo
cuentas a los responsables de estas
acciones antidemocráticas
el jefe militar del consejo soberano de
sudán declaró el estado de emergencia y
prometió unas elecciones que se
desarrollarían en julio de 2023 con el
objetivo de pacificar la situación del
país